Today, I'm gonna stray a bit from
the subject of language learning.
Uh, the other day I made a video about
the importance of being curious and the
importance of continuing to learn and,
and, and, uh, not only to challenge
our race, but to learn new things.
Uh, and the evidence that that's very
positive for us as we grow older, and
really very positive at any age, to be
curious and to be constantly learning.
And, uh, a number of comments were
very positive towards me and, you
know, thanking me for the, what they're
considered to be an encouraging message.
And people who are at, you know, either
50 or 60 or 70 were saying, yes, thank
you, and I'm the same way, and I, I'm
learning and then that's keeping me young.
And, and I, I think all
of that is, is positive.
And I know a lot of people...
I mean, we have only to look
at the two likely presidential
candidates in the United States.
One is 77, the other is 80, uh, to
realize that older people are still very
active, uh, and with a lot to contribute.
But I also wanted to say that as a person
who is obviously in the older category,
that I think older people in a way may
not always realize the extent to which
we are indebted to younger people.
It particularly came to light during
the Covid pandemic when younger people
had to sacrifice for the older people.
Younger people, who tend to be more
active out, more restaurants or concerts
or wherever, and they were forced to
forego some of these activities or
other restrictions which were imposed
on all of society, even though it was
really largely the vulnerable, not
exclusively, like there were a lot
of younger people who also got very
ill and ended up in a hospital in the
ICU and so forth, but overwhelmingly
was older people who suffered and
yet all of society and in particular
younger people had to sacrifice.
And when you then look at how many
societies are structured today, I
can only speak for Vancouver, but
the cost of housing is out of sight.
Younger people can't afford to buy homes.
Uh, older people, I think statistically
have more wealth than younger people,
and yet in our society, seniors
get a discount on public transit.
Uh, the health system overwhelmingly
looks after older people.
And the younger people
of course, pay taxes.
They work and they
support the older people.
So older people and, and of course over
we, it's older people who vote more than
younger people, which is kind of silly.
Younger people should get
out there and vote more.
But, uh, you know, rather than me paying
a, you know, having a discount on the
buses here, in a way I should pay more.
Um, because I, people of my generation
are a bigger burden on the health system.
Maybe we should pay more
into the health system.
Now, obviously you have people
who are not well off, uh, in old
age, and those people should get,
you know, assistance of some kind.
But a lot of people my
age are doing just fine.
And so in a way they should be
contributing more back into society.
Uh, you know, even something
like global warming.
Overwhelmingly, scientists believe that we
are going to have increasing difficulties.
I know this is controversial to some,
I don't, I'm not a scientist, but the
vast majority of scientists believe
that there will be predominantly
negative economic impact from climate
change, and the older people are not
gonna be facing these difficulties,
whereas the younger generation are.
And so for any of these different
points of view, it's fine to
respect older people, thank you
very much for having, you know,
live their lives and, and so forth.
And traditionally we respect people
with white or gray hair, which is fine.
Uh, and I think older people
tend to be perhaps physically
weaker or frailer or can be.
So I think they should
be treated with respect.
However, I think there should be some
recognition that older people maybe
should be in the tax system or in
the extent to which older people have
a free ride in the health system,
at least in countries like Canada
where we have a basically a universal
coverage system, that older people...
I, I wouldn't mind paying, uh, you know,
uh, I wouldn't call it wealthy seniors
tax, but something that recognizes
that, um, you know, I am taking out
more or potentially if I were to
get ill, Well I presumably will at
some point as I continue along here.
Um, we should be contributing
more and giving the younger
generation a better break.
So just some vague thoughts on that.
Uh, I'm sure that'll stir up a hornets
nest of comment and I can't say that
I've thought these things through
carefully, nor have I really researched
this, but it's just a feeling that
I had after seeing a lot of the
positive comments about me talking
about aging and learning and so forth.
So I think seniors also should be
contributing more to society than, than
they already have through their lives.
But even now at, at this stage, uh, you
know, at, at my stage in life, uh, I
believe we should be contributing more.
So there you have it.